[Music]
all right there you go friend that's an
ounce of weed and thanks for supporting
small business next hey could you sell
me more than an ounce sorry friend
that's the law what's simple farming
folk respect the law and each other now
it's fine I'll just go over the Anderson
weed farm and buy more there
well don't buy weed from them their weed
sucks it's a long way to drive out here
need to make it worth my while
it's cool amazon strike has more
people smoking weed than ever we have to
make sure tegrity weed stays ahead of
the competition we need to find a way to
get the weed to the people yeah like a
like a delivery service some way so
people don't have to drive out here and
even see the other weed farms you know
they got these scooters nowadays you
mean the things that almost killed us on
Halloween yeah I remember what if we use
a scooters to get directly to the
customers holy we could have
tegrity all over town
[Music]
I'm gonna have myself